Muhammad Ali explaining why he became a
Muslim
Muhammad Ali
glad to ask you
because of Islam and are you as good a
Muslim as you are a boxer
well it's not for me you know the word
Muslim mean one who submits and talent
to the will of God
one who submits in tolerance to the will
of God that's what Muslim mean so I I
don't know I cannot be the judge on how
much I submit entirely the will of God
God himself can only judge us so I can't
say how good I am and no true Muslim
will brag or even will even take a
chance on saying he's good he's halfway
good or not it's up to our Lord God to
be the judge see so I'm not going to say
one thing about uh how good I am because
I don't know we never get good enough
I'm always striving to be right yeah
so why did I change because I was raised
the Baptist and after touring the world
uh I found out that there are 600
million Muslims on the planet
what Jesus taught was good what Moses
taught was right what Buddha taught was
right what Krishna taught was right what
Isaiah a lot Noah God has always sent
prophets to different people at
different times with messages to those
people all of them are right Jesus made
a statement I come not to destroy no law
of the Prophet but to fulfill all of
God's prophets are right you gotta
believe in all of them so if a person
followed Moses and live like Moses
preached if they follow Jesus they
follow a lot any of the prophets the
religion is good but the people do
things in the name of the religion a lot
of Muslims do things they shouldn't do a
lot of Protestants a lot of Buddhas a
lot of Hindus live like they shouldn't
live but the religious itself the
religion is right but the people who
follow religion so it's the same God
essentially it's just different prophets
and people following a different
religion under the same God basically
well that's what we believe yes not
everybody believes that you know what I
really like what he just said is it's
not the religion's fault oh no yeah and
there's always crazy people not even
crazy people perfectly sane
well-educated good citizens will turn
around and be like all religion is awful
it's all terrible and you know they just
can't distinguish the good Muslims from
the bad the good Christians from the bad
I think he's talking about people in a
religion not doing the right thing that
is what he's talking about I'm saying I
find it very frustrating that people
can't understand this very basic thing
that he's saying and instead they just
cut off and hate all religions and
anyone that follows one is an idiot and
it's so small-minded in my opinion it's
frustrating that's a part of my life
that frustrates me watching people [ __ ]
all over religion because of a small
group of the people in that house how
many Muslims are there today well he
said there's 600 million 600 million
back then this was the thing I I don't I
didn't pay close attention when he
became a Muslim but it was a big thing
and I think because holy [ __ ] many two
billion people 2 billion so that's 25 of
the planet wow that's big that's big 25
of the planet and I couldn't even tell
you well I guess I could now through
online how many Muslims are there in
America because they are marginalized
and and the way that that word is used
only three and a half million America's
not terribly that's correct welcoming so
maybe to it so maybe that's why that is
interesting yeah but this was a big deal
and I remember being all the headlines I
love going to the corner store in Queens
what's up my friend could bacon egg and
cheese I got you bro yeah it was it was
I think there was a general feeling that
it was weird when he did this because he
was just like in a Christian American
one of us and then he became a Muslim
and it was it was very unique and
special it really stood out and not
necessarily special in a good way for
the culture at the time yeah I could see
why people were like taken back by it so
right so I choose to follow the Islamic
path because I've never sold so much
love I've never ever saw so many people
hugging each other kissing each other
praying five times a day the women in
the long garments the way they would eat
you can go to any countries
[Music]
you got a home you got a brother I chose
the Islamic path because they connected
me as a Christian in America I couldn't
go to the white churches as a Christian
that was for those people it did them
good it didn't do me good so the only
thing that made that's just true like
it's just crazy because like even with
the us watching the videos not knowing
what we're talking about at all it's
nothing but non-stop support and tons of
people wanting more and us to keep
researching into it and stuff I mean
it's crazy though like he couldn't even
go to a [ __ ] a regular Church Without
a Christian church because he's black
like that's the stupidest [ __ ] like they
really are more united I feel like
because I'm like even like you know how
black people in America have that thing
where like if you're two black guys in a
room it's like you got like that brother
[ __ ] going on you know what I mean like
okay I don't know I've never been a
black guy in a room alone with another
black guy but even like I don't know
I've seen videos where it's like the
president shaking all the white dudes
like Obama shaking all the white dudes
hands and then a black guy comes up and
it's like hey
I mean it's stuff like that and I feel
like it's the same way with like the
Islamic faith where Muslims have that
with each other Habibi I love that [ __ ]
oh baby but you have we have that as
Italian like no it's like not no we
don't it's you don't have clothes it's
not even close I'm telling you the truth
it's like oh we're both Italian
everyone's [ __ ] like I have some
Italian in them that is so not true do
you understand that in Middle America
where like mob people to them like they
look at it I'm telling you it's not even
remotely close to Muslims meeting each
other it's like legit Brothers I can't
disagree agree with that because I don't
I don't know it but I can say that that
does that exists amongst like people
they have certain little cultural things
that you know and Italians will walk up
and there is such warmth a hug a kiss
even men will hug and kiss each other
you don't see that among every culture
so yes I'm glad they have that also I
think it's diluted though I think you
need I definitely think it's diluted
because like I could see when you were
growing up and you were in your
neighborhood in New York and everyone's
like Italian and like come get away I'll
bite to eat it's like all that kind of
stuff and I just like I don't think it's
the same anymore even growing up in
Little Italy in the North End I just
don't oh you're Italian like it's just
not the same it's not even remotely
close because even like when I was in
Miami for an nft conference and I was
going out to dinner with my partner who
was Muslim and then other guys like they
just had like a connection because two
of them were Muslim like my partner and
one of the other dudes it's just like a
kind of thing I I don't know how to
really explain it any better than that
okay I haven't experienced it because oh
baby
I haven't been around enough situations
where I've seen you know two Muslim men
walk up to each other and how they how
they react what is the name I'd like to
learn more about you know women's place
in Islam because again stereotypically
what I've learned from the news and you
know the people people who are
completely ignorant of it as ignorant as
I am even more so the ignorant than I am
is that you know women are second-class
citizens and they they don't get really
get to speak and and have their own
opinions and they just have to follow
along I mean listen not as an American
woman that shit's not fine with me yeah
but like looking at the comments like
simply looking at my YouTube comments I
can instantly tell you that's just not
the case there's no there's no way
that's that's how it is yeah no it
doesn't feel that way and it's confusing
to me because I'm feeling nothing but
kindness and love and um Hospitality if
I will if you will but at the same time
I still have this other impression that
isn't fully you know it hasn't been
smashed out because all I've seen are
YouTube videos and had these had these
really wonderful ex you know comments
coming but I don't know the reality the
day-to-day reality and I'm I'm asking
that question because it's it's pressing
on me I'm excited to travel and I get to
see this [ __ ] firsthand in Mexico you're
just sitting in Mexico I'm going to
Mexico and I'm going to Europe a few
months later I got I got [ __ ] planned
all right let's keep going feel good the
only thing that made me feel free that
connected me with Saudi Arabia the
Islamic religion connect me with
Pakistan Morocco Syria I set that with
Colonel Gaddafi had done in this Palace
stayed overnight because of a Muslim as
a Christian I never could sit with
Christian leaders as a Muslim I sat with
sadata I said with President NASA
um uh markers of the Philippines IU Khan
of Pakistan before he died I've been
sent with Kings of all sheep's side of
Abu Dhabi Kings and people of these
nations have welcomed me as a brother
and I'm a citizen and now in America I'm
respected by all colors and throughout
the world as a Muslim see the name
Muhammad is the most common name in the
world there are more muhammads on the
planet the four billion people on Earth
and every third person is a Muslim you
read a [ __ ] book for me I'm not
condemning to other religion but for me
it's been a world figure John taking the
name Muhammad Ali which is the name of
my people for the brother of America
accepting the Islamic religion it was
better for me so I chose the Islamic
religion that's why I chose it
makes perfect sense just just looking at
the numbers if the if the numbers that
he said and what we just looked up are
correct back then they're almost a third
of the population of Earth were Muslims
and now we're looking at about 25 so the
actual ratio of Muslims to non-muslims
has shrunk and I wonder what that was
just I mean the deal around that is yeah
but who knows how accurate that's the
exact statement was and I mean who knows
and I Quantified that by like by saying
it right I started with that assuming
but assuming that they are that would be
something to talk about am I uneducated
or educated guess on that would be that
because the world is going to hell in a
hand basket and everybody thinks that
God is a fake construct of man-made
religion instead of actually taking a
real close look at it but whatevs keep
going awesome
I would like to be a minister don't you
think I preach pretty good very good
don't I make it plain yes don't you
understand now you ask me you asked me
some credit you asked me some pretty
tough questions but not a personality
huh I didn't if I didn't make the
Christians hate me I didn't make the
Protestants hate me I didn't make the
conversatement I told the truth I said
all of them are good if they live it
it's just the people who don't live it
so I chose the Islamic plan that's a
religion is a touch of thing religion
very few people can see ah some people
just have a Muslim don't want to hear
you some people just have a Protestant
pow pow yes I'm a Catholic pow pow this
is the power of this you see me do this
call me the greatest that's because I'm
more religious than I'm physical and I
study a lot and you may be surprised if
you hear me talk because you never heard
me talk this way but I know about it I
got about 45 lectures that I memorized
in my Ministry and I can tell you
something about all the religious books
all the religions because I'm the strong
believing God and Humanity that's why
I'm helping these boys that's why God
blesses me to be so great here because
all the time I've been here I've been
talking about god pushing god pushing
religion I'm not talking about me how
great how much money I got I'm always
giving the praise to God so that's why
I'm as great as I am in this physical
world because I push him first
well Muhammad we're running out of time
now that's wild
[Applause]
I'm gonna cry again
shut don't make fun of me women
sorry I can't help it I do I cry a lot
what are you gonna do I saw his daughter
fight in Reno how's that I remember
being fun I was going to the fights in
Reno it was fun all right thank you guys
so much for watching make sure to follow
follow me on Instagram Sonny fast oh
follow me Sonny's mother on Instagram I
don't care if you follow me don't follow
me follow him follow him his stuff's
better don't follow her just post
pictures of the dog and [ __ ] no one
cares yeah unless you want to you know
come on Twitter and help me save the
world and be on my team on Twitter all
day start liking her tweets it keeps her
distracted and [ __ ] she doesn't [ __ ]
bother me
follow her on Twitter then leave me
alone leave me alone please all right
thank you for watching make sure to
subscribe
[Music]
[Music]